THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER-
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE ON
GOING COVE IN NINETEEN RISKS.
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES OCCASION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE- THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
DISCIPLINE NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE FOUR. ONE ONE. ONE FOUR ONE.
I WILL MADE FROM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. HOLDENER
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I ASK ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN BEGINNER
HEARING. WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WILK WAS
PREVIOUSLY NOTICES PENDING
RECEIPT FOR TODAY'S HEARING. BUT
THAT BILL WAS HELD IN THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE HEARD IN
OUR COMMITTEE TODAY. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL'S
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. HERE WE WERE THERE IS. BEFORE
WE- WE'RE DOING. GREAT I DO KNOW
THAT SOME MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE OR CHAIRING OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT ARE MEETING AT
THIS POINT IN TIME SO WE HOPE TO
HAVE THEM JOIN US- LATER IN OUR
HEARING. RIGHTS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A FORM. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS- COMMITTEE SHARES CAN
IT'S TWO TIMES ON TESTIMONY-
EACH SIDE SHOULD BE PERMITTED AN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR. FOR OUR HEARING
TODAY. I EACH SIDE IS PERMITTED
ONE OR TWO WITNESSES- IT EACH
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH- AND THEN AFTER
THAT- IF YOU'RE IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE POSITION- OF THAT SIDE-
ASKING OTHERS TO SIMPLY LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THE WILL BE PERMITTED
TO TWENTY MINUTES OF MONEY.
INCLUDING SPEAKING TIME OF ANY
LEE WITNESSES. SO NOW WE WILL
BEGIN LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR WE WANT TO WELCOME
SENATOR CLAIRE THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TEN SIXTY ONE-
WELCOME YOU TO OUR COMMITTEE
YEAH COME ON IN. JOIN US NICE TO
SEE YOU THIS MORNING. GOOD TO
SEE YOU AS WELL THANK YOU. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. THE BILL- TEN
SIXTY ONE IN. D. A. THIS IS
ABOUT TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
SPECIAL ELECTIONS AND IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SCHOOLS WITH IN A SPECIFIC
DISTRICT OF GOVERNING BOARD IN
EDUCATIONAL POLICY- ON THESE
BOARDS IN THE EVENT OF A VACANCY
THE REMAINING BOARD MEMBERS MUST
CHOOSE TO EITHER HOLD A SPECIAL
ELECTION MORE MAKE A PROVISIONAL
APPOINTMENT TO SERVE THE
REMAINDER OF THE FAKE. TERM
VOTERS IN EACH JURISDICTION
ABILITY TO TERMINATE THE
APPOINTMENTS AND OPT FOR A
SPECIAL ELECTION. EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES THAT PROPONENTS COLLECT
THE SIGNATURES OF REGISTERED
VOTERS RANGING FROM ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT 25% DEPENDING ON
THE SIZE OF THE JURISDICTION TO
QUALIFY A SPECIAL ELECTION.
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS MUST PAY THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED FOR THE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS FOR MANY SMALLER
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS SPECIAL ELECTIONS TO
REPLACE PROVISIONAL APPOINTMENT
SEVERELY THREATEN THEIR
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND
ULTIMATELY DECREASE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENT SERVICES.
BUT SHOULDN'T TAKE MITCHELL
REQUIREMENT FOR NEW A SPECIAL
ELECTION TO REPLACE AN ELECTED
GOVERNING BOARD MEMBER RANGES
FROM 10230% OF REGISTERED VOTERS
DEPENDING ON THE NUMBER OF
VOTERS IN A JURISDICTION THERE
NEEDS TO BE PARITY IN THE
SIGNATURE PETITION REQUIREMENTS
PLACED ON INITIATING A SPECIAL
ELECTION FOR BOARD MEMBERS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ELECTED. OR
APPOINTED. THIS BILL WILL ALIGN
THE SIGNATURE THRESHOLD NEEDED
TO TERMINATE A PROVISIONAL
APPOINTMENT TO A SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WITH
THE EXISTING THRESHOLDS FOR
ELECTED MEMBERS. THE BILL
REQUIRES. WAITED ELECTIONS COST
EXPRESSED ON THE PETITION ON A
PER STUDENT BASIS FOR DISTRICTS
AND LASTLY IT PROVIDES DISTRICTS
THE OPTION TO COMBINE A SPECIAL
ELECTION WITH AN ALREADY
SCHEDULED STATE OR LOCAL
ELECTION TO STREAMLINE COSTS. IN
A MINUTE YOU'LL HEAR FROM A
WITNESS FROM THE MIDDLETOWN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
FACES A SPECIAL ELECTION THIS
YEAR. WHICH WILL COST ANYWHERE
FROM 250-008-0000 DOLLARS AND
WAS INITIATED BY ONLY NINETY TWO
SIGNATURES- AND LET ME BE CLEAR.
THIS BILL MAINTAINS THE SECIAL
ELECTIONS PROCESS FOR APPOINTED
BOARD MEMBERS. ARE AS A VALID
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT TO. HERE TO
TESTIFY- TODAY ARE CARLOS
MACHADO LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND LARRY
ALLEN PRESIDENT. OF THE
MIDDLETOWN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE FOUR
THANK YOU CENTER LEAD YOU HAVE
AN ORDER THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE
THE SPEAKER. PHONE I- I THINK
THAT- OF THE SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION'S GOING FIRST KICK
AT MISTER MACHADO WELCOME. THE
MORNING- SENATOR GLAZER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
CARLOS MACHADO AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SPONSOR OF
SB TEN SIXTY ONE TEN SIXTY ONE
WILL HELP INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION IN THE PETITION
PROCESS WHILE PROVIDING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD CRITICAL NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY TO MINIMIZE- MANY
THIS. YES A REGARDING IMPACT
THAT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE ELECTIONS ARE HAVING ON
STUDENTS IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
LODGING COST RANGE FROM HIGH
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
SMALL DINNER FOR SMALLER
DISTRICTS THESE COSTS CAN WREAK
HAVOC ON SCHOOL BUDGETS AND LEAD
TO CUTS TO STUDENT PROGRAMS AND
STAFF POSITIONS UNFORTUNATELY
MANY VOTERS ARE NOT AWARE THAT
THESE COSTS ARE BORNE BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND COULD REDUCE
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS. UNLIKE
ADDITIONS FISSIONS CONTAIN VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION NOT EVEN A
STATEMENT TO VOTERS OUTLINING
REASONS FOR THE ACTION SB TEN
SIXTY ONE ENSURES THAT
INFORMATION ON THE PETITION
MAKES IT CLEAR TO VOTERS THAT
SCHOOLS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RESULTING ELECTION COSTS- GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT FISCAL DISTRESS
THAT ELECTION COST CAN HAVE ON.
THE BILL ALSO ENSURES BROADER
VOTER SENSE IS REFLECTED IN THE
DECISIONS TO QUALIFY A PETITION
. TO HELP DISTRICTS MINIMIZE
ELECTION COST THE BILL EXPANDS
THE PERIOD DURING WHICH A SCHOOL
LIKE A SPECIAL ELECTION MAY BE
CONSOLIDATED WITH LOCAL OR STATE
ELECTIONS THIS CHANGE WILL HELP
WILL HELP DISTRICTS SAVE AS MUCH
AS- HALF OR MORE ON ELECTION
RELATED EXPENSES. MOREOVER BY
COMBINING THE SPECIAL ELECTION
WITH OTHER ELECTIONS SB TEN
SIXTY ONE WILL HELP INCREASE
VOTER PARTICIPATION IN DECISIONS
THAT WILL AFFECT THE EDUCATION
FOR STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT SB TEN SIXTY
ONE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER MACHADO. LEXICON
LARRY ALLEN TO TESTIFY STRADLIN
WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN GLAZER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M LARRY ON. SKEWS ME
I'M LARRY ON PRESIDENT OF
MIDDLETOWN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION
WHERE I'M SERVING IN MY FOURTH
YEAR. I JOIN THE BOARD FOR YEARS
AFTER RETIRING FROM THE DISTRICT
WHERE I TAUGHT FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. IT'LL DON IS A SMALL
RURAL DISTRICT. IN LAKE COUNTY
ABOUT TWO HOURS NORTHWEST OF
HERE. WE SERVE A LITTLE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS OVER
HALF QUALIFY FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS. WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT OUR STUDENTS AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE ASKING YOU
TO SUPPORT SB TEN SIXTY ONE. IN
DECEMBER ONE OF OUR APPOINTMENTS
WAS REMOVED BY SUCCESSFUL
PETITION WHICH REQUIRED ONLY.
NINETY FIVE- SIGNATURES WE WERE
LUCKY THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
CONSOLIDATE OUR SPECIAL ELECTION
WITH THE PRIMARY IN JUNE. IF THE
PETITION PROCESS WERE COMPLETED
EARLIER OR A LITTLE LATER WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN SO
FORTUNATE. US OF A SPECIAL
ACTION IS ESTIMATED TO BE
BETWEEN FIFTY AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS UP 24% OF OUR
TWO MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS FIRES
DESTROYED HOMES IN MANY OF OUR-
THE HOMES OF MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES. AS A RESULT OUR
ENROLLMENT HAS DROPPED ABOUT 13%
WITH SCHOOL FUNDING BEING TIED
TO ENROLLMENT OUR BUDGET HAS
DROPPED AS WELL. BECAUSE THE
BABY. WOULD FORCE US TO CUT. ONE
OF OUR TEACHING STAFF AND
INCREASE REMAINING CLASS SIZES
SMALLER AMOUNTS COULD MEAN WE
ELIMINATE OR LIMIT ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITY. CURRENT LAW HAS
ENABLED SMALL GROUPS TO THREATEN
THE FISCAL STABILITY OF OUR
DISTRICT ADJUSTING THE SIGNATURE
THRESHOLDS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THESE
PETITIONS REFLECT THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS ALIGNING THE
THRESHOLD. THOSE REQUIRED FOR
ELECTIONS. MAKES SENSE IN THAT
THE IMPACT ON THE DISTRICT IS
THE SAME WE LOSE A BOARD MEMBER
AND WE PAY FOR THE ELECTION. I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT SMALL
DISTRICTS LIKE OURS BY PASSING
S. B. TEN SIXTY ONE OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AS WELL
THANK YOU. MISTER ALAN. READY GO
FOR ALL THOSE WHO WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO JOIN IN SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WE ASK AGAIN THAT YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AN
INDICATION OF SUPPORT. WILL
BEGIN HERE IN OUR HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE BE TWENTY MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS YVONNE CARRY ON BEHALF
OF THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WERE PROUD CO
SPONSOR. ALSO REPRESENTING B.
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION SUCCESSOR. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING DOROTHY JOHNSON
HAPPY ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN OUR HEARING
ROOM SEE NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATE WOULD YOU
ASK. THERE'S ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO- PUT THEIR NAME ON THE
RECORD IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SIXTY ONE.
MODERATOR YOU THERE. NOW WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU I HEAR YOU IN A
REMOTE DEVICE THE BACK OF THE
HEARING ROOM BUT NOT IN OUR
SPEAKER SYSTEM.
HE SAID IT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE A
SHORT PAUSE WHILE WE WAIT TO FIX
OUR TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES SO
STAND BY.
HEARTBROKEN BETTER THINGS.
TESTING ONE TWO THREE TESTING
ONE TWO THREE.
OKAY A LETTER WILL BE RIGHT BACK
. TONTONS GET TESTING ONE TWO
THREE TESTING ONE TWO THREE. WE
DO HEAR YOU IT IS MUFFLED DAHLE
. OKAY TESTING ONE TWO THREE
TESTING ONE TWO THREE. MUCH
BETTER OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE-
RESTORED AUDIO CONNECTIONS-
MODERATOR CAN YOU ASK THOSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. GIVE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SIXTY ONE TO
SO INDICATE AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD
AND ACTIVISTS LIKE ARE. YOU%
SOMEONE CLEAR BY THE WAY AND
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING HIT ONE
ZERO REPLACE YOURSELF Q. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF- S. B. WE
ARE ON S. B. TEN SIXTY ONE. M.
OUR FIRST LINE WILL BE RIGHT
TENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ERICA SHE CAN I AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
LEVEL CREATE A JOINT UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT S.
B. ONE ZERO SIX ONE. SIX WILL GO
LINE ELEVEN. HI THERE MY NAME IS
ALEA ROMANS AND I AM A PARENT
WITH THREE CHILDREN IN THE LONG
RUN YEAH THE JOINT UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND I AM EXPRESSING MY
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
SIXTY ONE. I DISTRICT IS FACING.
A VERY EXPENSIVE SPECIAL
ELECTION THIS YEAR BASED ON A
PETITION FIFTY TWO PEOPLE. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED AND ALL THE
MEMBERS HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LIKE ME. RESHAPE IT IS
A VERY WE'VE ALREADY TEST
STORAGE TAKING NAY IN PHILLY AT
THIS POINT IN THE HEARING
PROCESS THANK YOU SO NO PROBLEM
YES AND- MODERATE WOULD BE GOING
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY AND FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE- PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR. A BI AT TEN SIXTY ONE AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN YOUR
OPEN. THANK YOU AMANDA DICKEY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AUTHENTICATION AND
SUPPORT. MR SURE THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
THERE AGAIN- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE- THE USE
ON THIS MATTER I DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION- CERTAINLY HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN SIXTY ONE. SEE NO ONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATE WOULD YOU ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE PHONE
LINES THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB TEN SIXTY ONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN SIXTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY TERRIFIC WILL BE GOOD
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR-
COMMENTS. SENATOR NEWMAN
PRESSURE. I'M ADDRESSING THE
GENTLEMAN FROM C. S. B. A. AND-
SIR I MUST HAS BEEN OBSERVATION
. SHE SB EIGHT ACCESS OTHER
EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES HAVE NEVER
MADE A FUSS OVER THIS ISSUE. BUT
SOMETHING'S HAPPENED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN AMERICA. THE
PARENTS BECAUSE A CULVERT GOT A
VIEW OF THE CLASSROOM. THEY
DIDN'T LIKE WHAT THEY SAW. SO
THEY'VE INITIATED SOME RECALLS
ACROSS THE LAND EVEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO. THEY ARE DISSATISFIED
IN RIGHTEOUSLY RIGHTEOUSLY AND
RIGHTLY SO. NOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU DON'T WANNA BE BOTHERED
. WITH RECALLS AND THE COST OF
THAT. BUT THIS IS THE CALL OF
THE VOTERS WHO THEY ELECT TO
THOSE SCHOOL BOARDS AND THEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON THE BOARDS
NEED TO BE ACCOUNTABLE. AND
THERE'S A MOVEMENT AMERICA AND
IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE THE RECALL
PROCESS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT. SO
MY POINT TO YOU SURE AS I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR C. S.
B. A. OVER THE YEARS I'VE SEEN
MANY OCCASIONS. FOR CS BA HAS
DONE THINGS THAT I THINK ARE
CONTRARY. TO QUALITY EDUCATION.
JUST MY OBSERVATIONS THAT AND
I'D LOVE IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND
PLEASE DO. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AND- YOU
ARE OUR MEMBERS ARE NOT TRYING
TO- CUT OFF THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
REMOVE A APPOINTED. BOARD MEMBER
TO A BOARD- THAT'S WHAT THIS
PETITION ACCOMPLISHES AND ALLOW
VOTERS TO FILL THAT VACANCY-
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THE
BILL AT THE KEY PROVISIONS IS TO
HELP REDUCE THOSE ELECTION COSTS
SO THAT IT DOESN'T IMPACT THE
STUDENTS THAT THOSE PARENTS ARE
INTERESTED IN INTEREST IN HAVING
THE DISTRICTSARE. ON AS
PRESIDENT ALLEN HAD MENTIONED IN
HIS TESTIMONY ARE THESE ELECTION
COSTS COULD LEAD TO- DISMISSAL
OF TEACHERS BECAUSE OF THE
REDUCED- BUDGETARY. ONES THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
DISTRICT IS THAT THE CLASSROOMS
GET LARGER A MAY LEAD TO A
REDUCTION OF ARTS AND- OTHER
ELECTIVES IN THE SCHOOL SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO BE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS BE MINDFUL OF
THE IMPACT OF THIS I GAIN SOME
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
WE CAN COMBINE THESE ELECTIONS
WITH OTHER LOCAL AND STATE
ELECTIONS AND THEN MAKE THIS
PROCESS- ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
IMPACT THAT IT DOES HAPPEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY ADJUSTING
THE VOTER SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENTS. BUT I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE-
GOING FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU EXPRESSED
ABOUT- ABOUT- BOARDS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE AND IF I
MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST DO A
SHOUT OUT TO MIDDLETOWN- I USED
TO REPRESENT THAT COUNTY. AND I
HAVE A DEAR. HEART FELT EMPATHY
FOR OUR SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE AN REPRESENTED NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES OVER THE
DECADES I THINK I'VE PROBABLY
REPRESENTED MORE SMALL
COMMUNITIES AND ANYBODY. AND THE
FACT I WAS JUST UP TO THE UPPER
LAKE HERE EARLIER A LOT THIS
YEAR- WE MANY WHERE DECADES AGO
ELEVEN EIGHTIES ACTUALLY WERE
ABLE TO SECURE BEFORE THE
ALLOCATION BOARD FUNDING FOR A
GYMNASIUM. IN UPPER LAKE AND
WE'RE CELEBRATING THAT THIS YEAR
STILL VERY NICE GLAD TO HAVE YOU
HERE FOLKS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
HE SENATOR NIELSEN WOULDN'T OUT
TO CENTER NEWMAN AND THANK YOU
MISTER I WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO
MAKE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
OBSERVATION- THEN THE VICE
CHAIRMEN MIGRATION IS. AT OUR
LAST SHOW YOU SEEN I THINK
BECAUSE THE POLARIZATION WHERE
POLITICS IS THE EXPLOITATION OF
A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS THAT DATE
WAY BACK TO AN EARLIER TIME THAT
WERE WELL INTENTIONED AT THE
TIME BUT IT BECOME- KIND OF
WEAPONIZED AS PEOPLE HAVE BECOME
MORE AND MORE POLARIZED MORE
MORE STRANGE AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHERE THAT'S HAPPENED
WHERE SCHOOL BOARDS- HAVE BEEN
SCHOOL TEACHER BECOME.
UNFORTUNATE BATTLEGROUNDS FOR
KIND OF PARTISAN WARFARE AND SO
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD MEASURE I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD IN THAT
AREA JOB- JUST TO ADD SOME RIGOR
TO PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT FOR
YOU KNOW BY NO FAULT OF YOUR OWN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS DON'T
SUFFER. THE COST WOULD PROVIDE
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO THE THESE
THE CONTENTIOUSNESS THAT COMES
WITH THE TANKS WHAT I AM AT
APPOINTMENT FOR A LIMITED ATION-
WE SHOULD HAVE FAITH ENOUGH IN
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS TO ALLOW
FOR AT. I JUST. TRY I DO TOO
GENERALLY TO GET GOOD AND RISK
MEASURE GLENN SUPPORT TO MOVE IT
- WHEN THE WHEN THE TOUCH PRO
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZED MOTION JUST A MOMENT
CENTER THEIR DOT DON'T THINK
IT'S ANY FOR QUESTIONS FROM THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TOPLAY YES THANK
YOU A PRIEST PEOPLE CAME AND
SPOKE. APPRECIATE THE CALM OF
THE AND WE JUST THIS DOES NOT
CHIU. THE LAWS FOR EXISTING
RECALLS FOR EXISTING FULL TERM
SCHOOL BOARD ELECTIONS IT DOES
NOT CHANGED IT JUST ADDRESSES
THE- THE ISSUE THAT SENATOR
NEWMAN- OF MENTIONED ED
THROUGHOUT THE CENTER NIELSEN-
IN THE ONE UP CATEGORY I
REPRESENT THE SMALLEST K.
THROUGH TWELFTH DISTRICT IN THE
STATE AND ROMAN IN THE SOUTHERN
BIG SUR COAST THERE SEVENTEEN
STUDENTS IN A K. THROUGH TWELFTH
DISTRICT AND FIVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. AND IF THEY WERE TO GO
TO ANOTHER HIGH SCHOOL BE A TWO
HOUR ROUND TRIP TO THE SOUTH OF
THE THREE AND A HALF HOUR ROUND
TRIP TO THE NORTH AND THE
HIGHWAY WAS OUT HALF THE TIME IN
SO IF THEY HAD A VACANCY IN THAT
DISTRICT. IT IS THIS MAY. BUDGET
AND IT WOULD BE A MONUMENTAL TO
FILL. AND WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT INJUSTICE AND SO. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. REBEKAH GOOD THOUGHTFUL
BILL THANK YOU CENTER LATER THAN
A RECOGNIZE THE MOTION CONSENTED
TO NEWMAN. THIS WOULD BE- DO
PASSED THE FIRST STEP TO BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- WITH THE
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. YOUR USE. ALL
RIGHT- SB TEN SIXTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI GLAZER
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG
LEYVA NEWMAN NEWMAN HI. OKAY
THAT- BILL- IS TWO TO ONE WITH
MEMBERS ABSENCE WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER
THERE OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO NOW
TO- AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO. SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
ALAN.
YOU COULD ARGUE THE DAGEN
MORNING CENTER ALLEN I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A QUIET AND RESTFUL
MORNING TO COME BEFORE US TODAY
WELCOME WELL COUPLE COUPLE CALLS
FROM THE CHAIR WHICH I
APPRECIATED- SO I DO I DO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS AND IS NOW
ON THIS POLICY AND- WE'RE WE'RE
VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU. AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
ON THIS ALTERNATE ABOUT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION DISCLOSURES WHICH-
I CERTAINLY CONSIDERED A
FUNDAMENTAL TRANSPARENCY TOOL
USED TO SHED LIGHT ON
INDIVIDUALS AND ENTITIES ARE
PROVIDING. FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
CANDIDATES FOR PUBLIC OFFICE- SO
CALIFORNIA. ARE CANDIDATES FOR
STATE ELECTED OFFICE INCLUDE THE
LEGISLATURE ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT THEY RECEIVE ON A SEMI
ANNUAL. OUR REPORTS THAT THEY
THAT THEY SUBMIT TO THE
CONFERENCE ACTORS STATE. AND
THEY'RE TO ACTIVITY REPORT
REQUIREMENTS SO CONTRIBUTIONS OF
A THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE MADE
TO A CANDIDATE DURING THE NINETY
DAY PERIOD PRECEDING AN ELECTION
MUST BE REPORTED WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AS WE ALL KNOW. THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR REPORTING
PERIOD OUTSIDE OF THE NINETY DAY
ALEXION PERIOD CONTRIBUTIONS A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE
MISTER REPORT WITHIN TEN DAYS.
AND THIS FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD IS REALLY HELPFUL FOR
PUBLIC AWARENESS OF LARGER
COUNTRY CONTRIBUTORS IN THE NON
ELECTION PERIOD BUT IT DOESN'T
PROVIDE TIMELY TRANSPARENCY IN.
FROM ANY SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS. ARE THE EXISTING
TIMELINE FOR FILING SEMI ANNUAL
ANOTHER ELECTION PERIOD REPORTS.
RESULTING CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER
FIVE THOUSAND THAT CAN GO MANY
MANY MONTHS BEFORE. THE
MISREPORTED AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS- YESTERDAY MISTER
CHAIR. ADDITIONALLY OF COURSE
THE CURRENT INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT TO
LEGISLATIVE CANDIDATES FOR NET
FOR YOUR FORTY NINE HUNDRED-
WHICH IS LESS THAN FIVE THOUSAND
ON ELECTION PERIOD REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. SO CANDIDATES FOR
THESE OFFICES ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO REPORT ANY LARGE INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THEY RECEIVE
OUTSIDE OF THE NINETY DAY
ELECTION PERIOD UNTIL OUR NEXT
SEMI ANNUAL OR- ELECTION PERIOD
FILING. SO IS ABOUT TRYING TO
INCREASE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
INFORMATION- THE BILL SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE PRINCIPLES BY
EXPANDING YOUR AROUND
CONTRIBUTION DISCLOSURES LAUREN
IN ON ELECTION PERIOD REPORTING
THRESHOLD AND THE REPORTING
TIMELINE. AT THE CHAIRED REMAIN
AND ENOUGH WE'VE BEEN WORKING
OUT SOME- SOME CHANGES TO THE
BILL MISTER CHAIR THAT I'M I'M
HAPPY FOR YOU TO ARTICULATE-
THAT I THINK YOU'RE- CHANGE
AROUND SOME OF THE DETAILS BUT
STILL. AT THE CORE GET TO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT WHICH IS
TO ENSURE THAT- THERE'S MORE
TIMELY DISCLOSURE OF OVER OF HOW
OF LARGE. CONTRIBUTIONS OUTSIDE
OF THAT NINETY DAY PERIOD. ALSO
WITH ME THIS MORNING WE HAVE
MICHAEL OUT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR- AND I DON'T. THANK YOU
SENATOR AL WILL GO TO YOUR FOR
FIRST WITNESS SEVEN STREET
BELOW. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
AND YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL OF SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF GOVERNMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA THE CORE PRINCIPLE I
THINK SENATOR ALAN ARTICULATED
PERFECTLY. IS TO- HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL CONTRIBUTIONS BE
REPORTED- AS- POSSIBLE PRESENT
LAW AS THE SENATOR NOTED DOES
ALLOW- A SO CALLED MAX OUT
CONTRIBUTIONS. OUTSIDE THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR REPORTING
PERIOD TO GO MANY MONTHS BEFORE
IT IS- REPORTED ACTUALLY. OFTEN
PASSED THE PRIMARY ITSELF. AND
SO- GOVERN FOR CALIFORNIA SIMPLY
LOOKING FOR- AS TRANSPARENT
SYSTEM AS POSSIBLE- ALSO
UTILIZING AS WE MOVE FORWARD
HOPEFULLY TECHNOLOGY WE OUGHT TO
BE- CAPITALIZING ON. COMPUTERS
TO HAVE EARLY REPORTING. WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION WITH
THE CHAIR AND WITH THE
CONSULTANT. BEFORE TO WORKING
YOU AS BILL MOVES FORWARD IF THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND FOR THAT
WE WOULD ASK AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR BELOW
HIS OR ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF FIVE THIS
LEGISLATION S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO. C. NINE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO IF YOUR SUPPORT. SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU.
ONE IT JUST QUEUED OUT MR SURE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IF THEY ARE
QUITE HELP ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SHOULD BE WITH THE
THIRTY SECOND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AS A REMINDER THE-
CALLING NUMBER. TODAY BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T HEAR IT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ONE. THE MEASURE WILL- GO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
TESTIFY. OR OR- IT IS BILL I AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU. WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES GO AHEAD. ONE
HI I'M JENNIFER CARROLL THE
HEALTH OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
GREENFIELD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WATER IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
Q. TWO TESTIFIED TODAY NOBODY.
NOBODY ELSE HAS QUEUED UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
READY GO TO NOW OPPONENTS OF
THIS LEGISLATION IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO TO PLEASE COME TO THE PODIUM
. SENILE AND JUMPING OUT OF
THEIR SEATS. READY GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO. YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO. MR SURE NOBODY IS
KILLING OUT OKAY TERRIFIC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
NEWMAN I DIED OF YOUR SENIORITY
HERE HERTZBERG IT WILL BEGIN
WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG AND- YEAH
WHAT WHAT CONCERNS ME ABOUT THIS
BILL CENTER ALLEN IS. THE AMOUNT
OF COMPLAINTS THAT YOU HAVE TO
SPEND TO RAISE MONEY I SPENT
PROBABLY 20% OF THE MONEY I HAVE
TO RAISE A COMPLIANCE NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO THE F. PPC HAS
JUST BEEN A GOTCHA GAME I FILE
THE FOUR HUNDRED SOME PAGE
COMPLAINT FOR YEARS AGO
INVOLVING SOMETHING THEY HAVE
ACTED ON IT INVOLVING A CAMPAIGN
THING THAT HAPPENED FOUR YEARS
AGO AND WHAT HAPPENS IS SOMEBODY
MISSES SOMETHING BY A DAY AND
THEY COME AFTER YOU. AND IT'S SO
HARD BECAUSE THERE'S SO FEW
PEOPLE THAT DO COMPLIANCE AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER THEY'VE GOT ALL
THE SHORT DEADLINES YOU MISSED
IT BY FOR TEN SECONDS AND THEY
FILED AN ACTION AGAINST YOU AND
THEN SOMEONE CLAIMS THAT YOU'RE
THIS HORRIBLE HUMAN BEING. ALL
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW YOU BASICALLY PUT
SOME BURDEN ON PEOPLE BOOK I
HAVE WORKED MY WHOLE LIFE ON THE
STUFF AND I'VE MADE MISTAKES
SOME OF THAT I WAS INVOLVED WITH
PROP. SIXTY EIGHT WAS INVOLVING
POP ONE THIRTY ONE ALL OF THIS
CAMPAIGN FINANCE MEASURE H. IN
LOS ANGELES AND AFTER I JUST AT
SOME LEVEL I KNOW SOMEBODY WILL
SAY YOU SHOULD BE ASKING. I'M
SORRY FOCUS ON THE DETAILS IN
THIS BUSINESS AND THE IDEA HERE
IS DISCLOSURE THE IDEAS.
TRANSPARENCY COMPLETE. WITH THE
I. D. NOT TOUCHING. THE IDEA IS.
IT IS THAT YOU GOT A FIVE DAY
WINDOW. AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
KNOW YOU WANT TO DISCLOSE
ADDITIONAL QUESTION TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS FINE. BUT NOW
THE RIGHT NOW EVEN THOUGH THE
NUMBER OF. OF WORK THAT REQUIRES
OF THIS TWENTY FOUR HOUR NOTICE
THAT THOUSAND DOLLARS ALL OF
WHICH IS IMPORTANT. BUT THE
AMOUNT OF EFFORT YOU GOT TO PUT
IT IN YOUR I'M SCARED TO DEATH
IF EVERY OTHER CANDIDATE SHOULD
BE SCARED TO DEATH BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW. AND
SO MY BIGGER ISSUES THE FIVE
DAYS OR IF YOU HAVE FIVE DAYS
WHEN AB IT'S- WE ARE ONLY TEN
DAYS. AGO SEARCH I WAS LATE. I
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING FROM TEN TO
FIVE. NOW WE'RE WE'RE GONNA STAY
WITH THE TEN K. AUGUST OF THE
TYRESE AND WE HAD A WHOLE. YEAH
AS THEY SAY IN. AS SANTA DENNIS
SAYS. REMIND ALL RIGHT AND
THERE'S BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONVERSATION I KNOW AND YOU'RE
YOU HAVE TO I MEAN THE GOOD. I
THINK WE ALL AGREE. SOME WAY TO
DO IT PERFECTLY IT'S FINE. I
JUST WENT OVER THE GOTCHA GAME
AND ALSO JUST THE CRUSH. AND
HAVE A VOICE ON THAT AND PEOPLE
ARE SCARED TO TALK ABOUT IT BUT-
IF THE TERRORIST ON THAT.
ALIBIED THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT
LEAST YOU'LL HEAR SOME
CONVERSATION ON THAT IN JUST A
MOMENT. OKAY A SENATOR NEWMAN
I'M SORRY I GUESS SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT. THAT PART OF
THE CONVERSATION. WOW IT'S
PROBABLY A LOT OF CONFIDENCE ONE
INCIDENT. OKAY BUT YOU KNOW YOU
FOR MY PART BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS. CERTAINLY A WORTHY. YOU
KNOW THE SET OF GOALS HERE OF%
THE COMPLETED WITH
TRANSPARENCY'S IMPORTANT. TO MR
BALOCH POINT I THINK TEN YEARS
AGO YOU CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT
THAT THIS WAS. ONEROUS I THINK
TODAY ALL THE TOOLS ARE.
THOROUGHLY IN PLACE SETTING WITH
SOME THOUGHTFUL. IMPLEMENTATION
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT ARE ALIGNED
. REPORTING SYSTEMS THIS
REPORTING PROCESS RIGHT NOW AND
THAT SHOULD BE THE GOAL AND I
THINK YOU CAN DO THAT. I THINK
YOU TO DRESS- MANY OF CENTER
HERTZBERG. ISSUES AROUND HERE- I
WOULD PROBABLY URGE. SOME
CONSIDERATION ABOUT UNITY
PROVISIONS FOR CURE- MAYBE A
SLIDING SCALE YOU KNOW TO WEAR
TO HIS POINT WHERE IT'S NOT
BINARY YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT
EITHER PURE OR GUILTY. BUT BUT
THE INCENTIVES TO REPORT THEIR
OF THE OBLIGATION REPORT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT THE
DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS SO WE
ALL USE- IF USED RUSSIAN
TREASURY WE ALL USE. SYSTEMS ARE
THOSE SYSTEMS SHOULDN'T BE TOO
HARD TO INTEGRATE WITH THESE
REPORTING PROCESS ESPECIALLY
WITH THE IPC SYSTEMS DR GRANT
SUPPORT THOSE SANCTIONS LIVER
WORK LEFT HAPPY HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR IT. AND TO MOVE AT THE
PERFECT TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN- CENTER I WANT
TO. JOIN IN THIS CONVERSATION I
HAVE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
IN THIS SPACE AND ADDS THAT
OTHERS IN THE COMMITTEE
VINDICATED YOU TRANSPARENCY IS A
HEALTHY THING WE WANNA. ALLEN
COURAGE THAT. BUT THE CHALLENGE
THAT I WAS HAVING WITH THE WITH
YOUR BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN. IS I
WAS TRYING TO SEE WHAT PROBLEM
ARE WE SOLVING WHAT WHAT PROBLEM
ARE WE SOLVING AND- I'LL BY
DEFINITION IN YOUR BILL- YOU BY
NOT IDENTIFIED A PROBLEM UNTIL
AT LEAST SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENED. AT THREE MONTHS PRIOR
TO THE ELECTION AND IS A
CONTRIBUTION LOWER THAN FIVE
THOUSAND BUT ABOVE- A THOUSAND.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
SPEAK TO ANYTHING SPECIFICALLY
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN OUR
ELECTION CYCLE GOING BACK TWO
DECADES THAT WE'VE HAD IT. AND
WE HAD THESE DISCLOSURES WHERE
YOU FEEL THERE'S BEEN AN ABUSE
THAT IN A MINUTE ELATION AS
OCCURRED. WHERE SOMEONE HAS
RECEIVED CONTRIBUTIONS BECAUSE
OF THE FAILURE TO DISCLOSE
MONTHS AND MONTHS BEFORE THE A
LOT. OF VOTERS HAVE BEEN ILL
SERVED. WELL I DON'T THINK
THERE'S BEEN ABUSE BUT I DO
THINK THAT THE VOTERS BEEN ILL
SERVED AND SO I WE YOU AND I
SPOKE ABOUT HOW THERE ARE THESE-
THE PAPER REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
OF THE AND SO LITTLE EARLY IN
THE CAMPAIGN SO DO YOU HAVE SO
THAT TAKES SO MUCH TIME TO FIND
OUT BASICS ABOUT A CAMPAIGN
FINANCE- YOU KNOW IN AN EARLIER
STAGE IN THE CAMPAIGN SO ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS HAVE
SOME MORE TIMELY REPORTING AND
DISCLOSURE. BUT THINGS LIKE THE
FIVE TO TEN DAYS NO PROBLEM I
MEAN THAT THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT'S IT THAT'S IT
THAT'S NOT A MEANINGFUL AT THE
CONCESSION FROM UP TRANSPARENCY
PERSPECTIVE BUT IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
GOTCHA GAME THAT THAT THE
SENATOR WAS TALKING ABOUT SO
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I'M SO
HAPPY TO- TO BE FLEXIBLE ON BUT
THE BUT THE BROAD CONCEPT OF.
GETTING A LITTLE BIT MORE-
SHINING A LITTLE MORE LIGHT ON
ON ON A ON A CAMPAIGN FINANCING-
AT THE EARLIER STAGE SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT LITTLE MONTHS
UNTIL THE SEMI ANNUAL REPORT TO
KNOW WHAT THE BASICS ARE OF
SOMEONE ELSE'S CAMPAIGN IS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO GET OUT HERE THAT
IT- SO FROM MY POINT OF VIEW
IT'S HARD TO SEE A CONTRIBUTION
GIVEN A YEAR OR TWO YEARS BEFORE
THE ELECTION. AND THAT THAT THE
FACT THAT IT'S NOT DISCLOSE FOR
OF A NUMBER OF MONTHS AS A
MATERIAL AFFECT AN ELECTION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT HAPPENING FOR
ONE OR TWO YEARS LATER SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN OUR CURRENT ELECTION
YEAR TWENTY TWO CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT WERE GIVEN IN TWENTY OR
TWENTY ONE- THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
SEMIANNUAL REPORTING OBLIGATIONS
PRIOR TO THAT POINT IN TIME. AND
THERE'S DISCLOSURE MONTHS AND
MONTHS BEFORE AN ELECTION WHERE
IF YOU HAD SOMEONE WHO FELT THAT
THAT WAS INAPPROPRIATE- THAT
THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THERE
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY ONCE IN
MONTHS OF OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE. A
ISSUE OF IF YOU DECIDED TO DO
IT- SO I DON'T REALLY SEE WHERE
WE'RE CLOSING ANY KIND OF
TRANCE. GAP IN THE PRIOR
ELECTION YEAR BEFORE THE
ELECTION. NOW NEVERTHELESS I DO
HAVE A CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTION
TO PUT FORWARD. I THINK WHERE
THERE IS A GAP IN OUR DISCLOSURE
HAPPENS DURING THE ELECTION
YEAR. FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE A
CANDIDATE- THAT AT THAT- THAT-
WITH THE DECLARED IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR OR YOU'RE AN ACTIVE
CANDIDATE. BUT IN JANUARY OF THE
OF THE YEAR UNTIL THE BEGINNING
OF MARCH. THERE IS NO DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS- IF YOU DON'T. SEE
THE CONTRIBUTION OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE HAVE A DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENT NINETY DAYS BEFORE
OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE.
SO THERE'S A GAP THERE- AND IN
FACT ANY CONTRIBUTION THAT YOU
RECEIVED IN THE FIRST. ALMOST
FOUR MONTHS OF THE YEAR YOU'RE
NOT EVEN REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE
UNTIL THE END OF APRIL THE FIRST
PRE ELECTION REPORT. SO I DO SEE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONTRIBUTIONS CLOSER TO ELECTION
I DO SEE YOU GET INTO THIS PLACE
THE SPACE OF POTENTIALLY HAVING
INTO A MATERIAL EFFECT ON
ELECTION. ADD TO THAT THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DOING ALL MAIL
BALLOTS. THE ACTUAL OPERATIVE
DATE OF THE ELECTION IS NOT IN
OUR CASE JUNE SEVENTH AND THIS
YEAR IT'S ACTUALLY BEGINS THE
BEGINNING OF MAY SO ACTUALLY.
THE THE ABILITY TO AFFECT AN
ELECTION I CAN ACTUALLY HAPPENED
A LOT EARLIER- GIVEN THE- HOW
WE'VE IMPROVED OUR ACCESS TO THE
BALLOT OKAY. SO I DO SEE AND
THIS IS A CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTION I'M I'M WILLING TO
HAVE YOUR BILL GO FORWARD WITH
MY SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEES
WILLING. BUT HERE'S WHERE I
THINK THE GAP COULD BE CLOSED
THAT HAS A MATERIAL EFFECT WOULD
BE MAKING TWO CHANGES. NUMBER
ONE IT WOULD BE CREATING AN
EARLIER PRE ELECTION REPORT ANY.
DAY AND I WOULD SUGGEST TO BE AT
THE CLOSE OF THE PERIOD OF
FEBRUARY. TO BE REPORTED IN THE
BEGINNING OF MARCH. AND NUMBER
TWO WOULD BE TO TAKE THE-
THOUSAND DOLLAR DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS THAT CURRENTLY IS
NINETY DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
AND MOVE IT TO A HUNDRED DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION. NOW YOU'VE
CLOSED THE COMPLETE GAP. IN THE
ELECTION YEAR FOR DISCLOSURE BY
DOING THOSE TWO THINGS YEAH. I
THINK THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH MORE
THAN WHAT YOUR BILL WILL
REQUIRE. IT ONLY CREATES A ONE
OBLIGATION OF A CANDIDATE WHICH
IS THE NEW PRE ELECTION AT THE
END OF FEBRUARY. TO BE REPORTED
THE BEGINNING OF MARCH. AND THEN
IT ADDS AT TEN DAY EXTENSION TO
THAT THOUSAND DOLLAR REPORT. YOU
CLOSE THE GAP. AND HE A YOU
TAKEN AWAY THIS REPORTING
OBLIGATION AND OF AND A YEAR
BEFORE THE ELECTION. WHICH I
THINK CREATES A- A- PAPERWORK
TRAP FOR ANY CANDIDATE. BECAUSE
YOU'RE ONLY TRYING TO CLOSE.
BETWEEN TWENTY- FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR WHATEVER ENDING BELOW
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ASSETS-
THAT THAT WOULD BE MY
CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTION HOW TO
DO WHAT I THINK YOU ACCOMPLISH
WHAT MUCH OF WHAT YOU WANT
WITHOUT READING THAT PAPER
RETRACTED. THAT WE'VE ALL FALLEN
INTO. SO YOU ARE YOUR
SUGGESTIONS VERY WELCOME- THE
ONLY THING I CAN THINK OF IS
THAT- LEASE ON THE ELECTION YEAR
IS THAT WE SEEM WE ARE
STRUGGLING BETWEEN WHETHER GONNA
HAVE MARCH PRIMARIES IN JUNE
PRIMARY SO WE HAVE TO JUST
FIGURE OUT. HOW THAT PLAYS BASED
ON A DIFFERENT PRIMARY DATE. THE
ONLY THE ONLY THE ONLY PUSH BACK
I'D I'D I'D PUT ON THE ON THE
QUESTION OF PREVIOUS YEARS. IS
THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT I'M THE
EARLY DAYS OF ELECTION ALSO
INVALID SELECTION RIGHT IT CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THE MONEY
GAME YOU KNOW WHO RAISES THE
MOST MONEY OUT THE GATE FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN AN ELECTION STARTS.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR. BUILDING UP TO
THE ELECTION DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THAT EARLY FUNDRAISING IS AN
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT. IN HELPING
TO DETERMINE THE WAY THAT OUR
RACE- EVOLVES AND OF COURSE YOU
KNOW THERE'S ALSO INFLUENCE THAT
THAT THE MONEY CAN POTENTIALLY.
SHED LIGHT ON OUR TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS SO. I'M I'M I'M WHAT I
LOVE TO DO- YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION
ASTIR JERRY IS TO JUST. MAYBE
FIGURE OUT A- A SYSTEM FOR THE
PRE FOR THE PRE ELECTION YEARS.
THAT PROVIDES SOME MORE
DISCLOSURE THAN WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. BUT THAT IS NOT AS
RIGOROUS. AS WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING FOR THE ELECTION
YEAR. AND I THINK IF WE CAN.
WORK WITH THAT CORE CONCEPT ON
SOME DETAILS TOGETHER AS IF THE
BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
I THAT WOULD I WAS REALLY MAKE
ME FEEL. HAPPY THAT I WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE FINE TO DO THAT. I
WOULD NOTE THAT- AN EXAMPLE THAT
YOU JUST GAVE. THAT THOSE WHO
WANT TO SHOW THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
AS A MEASURE OF STRENGTH- THAT
DOESN'T CONFORM WITH THE
ELECTION. REPORTS THE SEMIANNUAL
REPORTS HAS EVERY RIGHT TO GO
AHEAD MAKE ANY DECLARATION OR
DISCLOSURE. THEY HAVE. ON THE
POSITIVE SIDE- AND ON THE
NEGATIVE SIDE THAT SOMEHOW
SOMEONE TAKING A CONTRIBUTION A
YEAR BEFORE THE ELECTION. I
WOULD SOMEHOW SOMEHOW HAVE
IMMUNITY. IS IT REALLY THE CASE
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
SEMI ANNUAL REPORT. FOR FIVE OR
MORE MONTHS BEFORE AN ELECTION
WHERE ANYONE CAN SEE THOSE
DISCLOSURES AND TAKE WHATEVER
MAKE WHATEVER OPINION THEY WOULD
HAVE. ABOUT IT. NEVERTHELESS I
APPRECIATE THE GOALS THAT YOU'VE
ESTABLISHING YOUR BILL I THINK
THAT WE CAN WORK ON THOSE
TOGETHER. AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD IF THE COMMITTEE AGREES
. PRESIDENT MODESTO IS TO REALLY
GO AHEAD. YEAH BRIEFLY. I THINK
CENTER ON AND I THINK YOU MITCH
REALLY GOOD POINT. EARLY MONEY
GOES MOSTLY UNEXAMINED- BUT IT
HAS A HUGE IMPACT- AS TO
POSITIONING AS TO VIABILITY AND
I THINK IT'S RELEVANT. TO SHED
AS MUCH LIGHT AS POSSIBLE AS TO
WHO SUPPORT SECOND WHO IS ME
THEY CAN'T A VIABLE. I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT WE OFTEN
FORGET THAT. THAT THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD- IS. THE REASON
WHAT WE ARE YOU KNOW FOR THE
AVERAGE PERSON A THOUSAND BOX IS
REAL MONEY. RIGHT REAL MONEY AND
SO IT IS MORE THAN WORTHWHILE TO
ME. TO HAVE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE A BASIS FOR SAYING. YOU
YOU KNOW WHO GIVE SMALL YOU GUYS
BIG MONEY BIG MONEY IS WHAT
DETERMINES VIABILITY- CONTEXT I
THINK IT'S EVERYTHING YOU THINK
TO DO YOU KNOW TO YOUR THINKING.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE BY
THE SUBMISSION DEADLINES ARE A
BIG DEAL IS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
GETS REPORTED THOSE ARE THE
THOSE ARE THE- THE TRACTION
POINTS OF THE MILESTONES YOUR-
YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN THE SCOOTY
SUPPLIED. SO I THINK WE SHOULD
ASPIRE TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE TO
REAL TIME REPORTING. TO MR
BALOCH POINT ABOUT SYSTEMS- AT
SOME POINT DOWN THE ROAD IF YOU
KNOW THERE SHOULD BE MORE OR
LESS CONTINUAL. AND THAT LEVEL
TRANSPARENCY WOULD DO TWO
THINGS- IT WOULD GIVE. VOTERS TO
MAKE FULL. MISTER WHO SUPPORTS
HIM. BUT ALSO GIVE A VERY
DIFFERENT BASIS FOR YOU KNOW THE
REPORTING ON RACES AND I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD TAKE SOME OF THE
STRESS OUT OF THESE MILESTONES.
MULLIN I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA-
REMEMBER WHO PAYS. FOR ELECTIONS
IT'S NOT THE LITTLE GUY. SENATOR
JUST I JUST TO SAY MY COMMON-
WHICH- NEWMAN AYE AYE COMPLETELY
AGREE DISCLOSURE DISCLOSURE
DISCLOSURE DISCLOSURE. HOW CAN
YOU DO THAT WITHOUT CHAU
BURDENING THE SYSTEM WOULD COST
SO MUCH MONEY AND YOU PLAY THE
GOTCHA GAME THAT WOULD CONCERN
BY. COFFEE INFORMED. THINKING
EARLIER- BUT IT WAS AND IT WAS
IN THE DANNATT BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
THIS FOR SO LONG AND I. HAVE
SPENT SO MUCH OF MY LIFE
INVOLVEMENT WE GET ALL THE VOTER
STUFF TOGETHER IN THE SAME DAY
VOTING. TO ENHANCE PARTICIPATION
ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY IT'S SO
FUNDAMENTAL TO WHAT HAPPENS IN
THIS COMMITTEE IN WHICH WE
SHOULD DO OUR DEMOCRACY SO I'M-
I'M ALL WITHIN A BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT ELEMENT I JUST WANT TO
BALANCE OUT THOSE ELEMENTS OF
COST. AND GOTCHA IN TERMS OF
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. AND YEAH
WEEK IF WE COULD DO REAL TIME
REPORTING THAT WOULD BE THE
BEST. AT ALL TIMES TO BE THE
BEST FOR EVERYTHING. YEAH I MEAN
OF COURSE THAT'S A THAT'S A
BURDEN RIGHT I MEAN SO. THAT'S
A- LOT OF. TWENTY THREE NO NOT
NOT REALLY IT'S NOT THAT MUCH OF
A BURDEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FILL OUT THE REPORTS THAT
LITERALLY. THERE WAS A SYSTEM
BUILT WITH THE SECTOR STATES
OFFICE WHEN THE CONTRIBUTIONS
MADE YOU CLICK THE BUTTON. THAT
IS NOT VERY HARD TO DO. YOUR
POINT IS WE JUST DO REAL TIME
REPORTING AND BUT THE REPORTS A
LOT WHAT DO YOU DO REAL TIME
REPORTING REPORTS AREN'T THAT IT
WOULD TAKE UP THE THIRD PARTY
INTERMEDIARY AND IT BECOMES A
WHOLE DIFFERENT PLACE I THINK
ISN'T WHAT LET'S TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I'M NOT. YOU KNOW. BUT I
THINK THERE'S SOME WAYS TO DO IT
ELECTRONICALLY WE SPENT SOME
TIME WITH SECRETARY PER DIEM.
FOR CAME YOUR CENTER AND IF YOU
RECALL WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY
TO UPDATE THE CALYX EXISTENCE.
AND TO MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE
IT'LL SLOWER COMING TO FORTUNE
ON THAT. BUT I DO THINK
TECHNOLOGICALLY THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF WAYS TO. HUNDREDS
MAYBE OVERSTATEMENT BUT THERE'S
A NUMBER OF WAYS WE CAN BE
CREATIVE. IN CALIFORNIA. AND
COST A BUNCH. THE RELEASE. TO DO
. YEAH FREESHIP OF COMMENTS. A
FOR COMMENTS CENTER DEALS YOU
HAVING NO OKAY ALL RIGHT- SENATE
ALLEN LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I LOOK
I APPRECIATE THESE COMMENTS AND-
I YOU KNOW THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
THIS IS THE WISDOM OF THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS WHEN WE HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO GET AN IDEA
ON PAPER AND THEN START THE
DISCUSSION AND I JUST APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU ALL. HAVE
GRASS GOALS THAT WE HAVE HERE
AND NOW IT'S A MATTER OF
TINKERING THE BILL TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE REACH THOSE GOALS
IN A WAY THAT IS REALLY THE MOST
EFFICACIOUS. FOR OUR SYSTEM AND
DOES. NOT END UP. PUTTING MORE.
UP MARKET MORE COMPLIANCE BURDEN
ON FOLKS WITHOUT THE
CONCOMITANT- TRANSPARENCY GOAL
SO. I'M TO THIS APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL TODAY AND
- LOOK FOR TO A ROBUST
DISCUSSION AS THIS MOVES TO
REPROACH- TO SEE IF WE CAN HONE
ASPECTS OF THE BILL A TO RETURN
CALLS. IT THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
WITH THEM IN A RECOGNIZED MOTION
CENTER NEWMAN. TO MOVE THE BILL
AS IS- SO THIS WOULD BE PASSED
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THE CONSULTANT CALL THE
ROLL. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI GLAZER
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG
. HERTZBERG HI LEYVA NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN HI OKAY THAT BILL
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE TO ONE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I'M GONNA TURN
THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE YEARS
I'LL BE PRESENTING THE NEXT BILL. YEAH. YEAH THE.
ALL RIGHT SHERMAN GLAZER YOU
HAVE A BILL BEFORE US TODAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT YOUR- SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THANK YOU I CHAIRED NIELSEN GOOD
EIGHTY WOULD PERMIT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE I ONE
UNDERSCORE PERMIT. THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO CERTIFY A REMOTE
ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEM
AND I'M GONNA USE THAT WORD A
LOT REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY
MAIL BUT I'M TO USE THE INITIALS
TO MAKE IT A LITTLE EASIER R. A.
V. B. M. THE SYSTEM PROVIDES AN
OPTION- FOR VOTERS WITH A
QUALIFYING DISABILITY TO
ELECTRONICALLY RETURNED THEIR
BALLOTS. UNDER CURRENT LAW
VOTERS ARE ABLE TO USE IN OUR A.
V. B. M. SYSTEM TO
ELECTRONICALLY RECEIVE AND
COMPLETE A BALLOT THAT SYSTEM
ALLOWED TO VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES TO USE THEIR
ACCESSIBLE HOME TECHNOLOGY. TO
READ MARK THEIR BALLOTS
PRIVATELY AND INDEPENDENTLY.
HOWEVER VOTERS REQUIRED TO
RETURN A PRINTED COPY AS THEY
WOULD RETURN TO TRADITIONAL
PAPER VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT. WHILE
REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTING HAS
IMPROVED VOTING AT HOME FOR MANY
VOTERS WITH DISABILITIES. IS
STILL DIFFICULT FOR BIRDS WITH
VISUAL AND DEXTERITY IMPAIRMENTS
TO VOTE PIVATELY AND
INDEPENDENTLY YOU'RE USING THE
CURRENT SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE
VOTER WHO IS BLIND USING THE
SYSTEM WOULD NOT HAVE A PRIVATE
AND INDEPENDENT BUILDING
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE SOMEONE WOULD
NEED TO HELP THEM WITH PRINTING
THE BALLOT AND COMPLETING THE
ENVELOPE REQUIREMENTS. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY PERMITS PERMITS
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
CERTIFY AND R. A. V. B. M.
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES AN OPTION
FOR VOTERS WITH A QUALIFYING
DISABILITY TO ELECTRONICALLY
RETURNED ABOUT. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ALSO PROVIDES THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WITH THE
ESTABLISHED AND ACCESSIBLE WAY
FOR VOTER WITH A QUALIFYING
DISABILITY TO SUBMIT. A
SIGNATURE TRONIC LEE. UPON SERVE
OF A- ELECT BALLOT RETURN
OPTION. UPON CERTIFICATION OF AN
ELECTRONIC BALLOT RETURN OPTION
I COUNTY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PERMIT A VOTER WITH A QUALIFYING
DISABILITY. TO USE THAT ARE A V.
V. M. SYSTEM. IF THE SYSTEM IS
NOT AVAILABLE FOR USE IN A
VOTERS COUNTY VOTER WITH A
QUALIFYING DISABILITY WOULD BE
ABLE TO RETURN A BALLOT BY FAX.
NOW I THEIR SECURITY CONCERNS
WITH THIS CHANGEYES. AND THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS SHOULD BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN CERTIFYING A
SYSTEM. IN THE END IF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE DOES NOT FEEL
THE SYSTEM IS READY FOR USE FOR
WHATEVER REASON. THEN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SHOULD NOT
APPROVE THAT SYSTEM. HOWEVER IN
THE MEANTIME WE SHOULD NOT
PREVENT A GROUP OF VOTERS FROM
BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY IS
ABOUT IMPROVING ACCESS FOR
VOTERS WHO FACE A BARRIER WHEN
SEEKING TO VOTE IN AN
INDEPENDENCE. AND PRIVATE MATTER
THIS BILL IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TO BE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WITH ME THIS
MORNING IS PAUL SPENCER WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND JEFF TOM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER SPENCER.
WELCOME MR SPENCER PLEASE
PROCEED. ONE OF THE I'M NOT HIM
. NO I'M THE OTHER WITNESS.
WE'LL HEAR FROM YOU THEN SIR
OKAY THE STOCK BY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR- I MY
NAME IS JEFF TOM I AM THE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
THE BLIND. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK CHAIR GLAZER- FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL AND URGE ITS
SUPPORT BY THIS COMMITTEE.
IMAGINE YOU ARE A CALIFORNIA
VOTER WHO OPTS TO VOTE BY MAIL.
IMAGINE IF YOU WILL THAT MARKING
THE BALLOT REQUIRED A SPECIAL
PENCIL. AND THE ONLY THING
SPECIAL ABOUT THIS PENCIL IS
THAT ONCE YOU MARK YOUR BALLOT
IT WOULD BECOME INVISIBLE TO
YOU. NOT TO ANYBODY ELSE BUT YOU
. THAT'S THE DILEMMA I AM IN
WHEN I MARK MY BALLOT ON MY
COMPUTER AND SEND IT TO MY
PRINTER. I CANNOT. I CANNOT KNOW
WHETHER THE PRINTER RAN OUT OF
INK OR SOME OTHER PROBLEM
OCCURRED. SO I CAN EITHER HAVE
TWO OPTIONS I CAN EITHER SHOW IT
TO SOMEONE ELSE AND GIVE UP MY
PRIVACY. OR I CAN TAKE IT ON
FAITH. AND SEND THE BALLOT IN.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLEVIATE THAT
PROBLEM AND ALLOW ME TO VOTE
COMPLETELY PRIVATELY AND
INDEPENDENTLY. SOMETHING THAT
ALL VOTERS WITH OR WITHOUT
DISABILITIES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO. IT WILL ALSO HELP PEOPLE WHO
DO NOT OWN A PRINTER. AND OF
COURSE WILL HELP PEOPLE WITH
OTHER DISABILITIES INCLUDING
DEXTERITY DISABILITIES. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS BILL I
THINK IT IS A REASONABLE BILL
AND HAS THE APPROPRIATE
REQUIREMENTS BUILT INTO IT TO
ASSURE THAT THE BILL WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY. YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER TOM MISTER
SPENCER. THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAUL SPENCER
AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY. IN THE
VOTING RIGHTS PRACTICE GROUP
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
PROTECTION ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF ALL
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. AND WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY. THIS BILL
PERMITS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO CERTIFY IN OUR AB BM- SYSTEM
THE PROVIDES AN OPTION FOR
SOMEBODY WITH A QUALIFYING
DISABILITY. ELECTRONICALLY
RETURNS ARE VALID. SO IT IN
ORDER FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES TO HAVE A TRULY
PRIVATE AND INDEPENDENT VOTING
EXPERIENCE MANY STATES AND
LOCALITIES OF ADOPTED ELECTRONIC
BALLOT RETURN OPTION. AS PART OF
THEIR ABSENTEE VOTING SYSTEM.
BASED ON RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY FOURTEEN STATES HAVE
SOME FORM OF ELECTRONIC BALLOT
RETURN FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES. FEDERAL LAW IS NOT
A BARRIER TO LECTURE ON THE
BALLOT RETURN. FURTHERMORE THE
STATE'S FAILURE TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBLE RETURNED OUT RETURN
OPTION FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES IS LIKELY A
VIOLATION OF TITLE TO THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
AND SECTION FIVE OH FOUR OF THE
REHABILITATION ACT. SO THE LACK
OF AN ELECTRONIC BALLOT RETURN
OPTION FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES VIOLATES THESE LAWS
BECAUSE OF A LACK WILL ACCESS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA OFFERS AN
ELECTRONIC BALLOT RETURN OPTION
FOR ANOTHER VOTERS MILITARY AND
OVERSEAS VOTERS. SO MILITARY AND
OVERSEAS VOTERS CAN RETURN ABOUT
BY FAX. THERE'S ALSO NOTHING TO
CURRENTLY PREVENT THEM FROM
SENDING THE BALLOT BEGET KEY
FACTS TO THEIR COUNTY ELECTIONS
LINE. ADDITIONALLY ARE THERE'SA
FEDERAL AGENCY THAT WILL ACCEPT
EMAIL BALLOTS ON BEHALF OF
MILITARY AND OVERSEAS VOTERS AND
THEN FAX IT DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICE. SO SB
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN OR FORTY WILL
CREATE ELECTRONIC RETURN OPTION
IT'S BUILT ONTO THE EXISTING
REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL
SYSTEM AND WILL USE MODERN
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY INSTEAD OF
RELYING ON FACTS. THE
TRANSMITTER BALLOTS RECEIVED BY
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICES PRINTED. AND THEN COUNTED JUST LIKE
OTHER BALLOTS. THERE ARE
SECURITY RISKS WITH EVERY
ELECTION SYSTEM BUT WE MUST
BALANCE SECURITY WITH
ACCESSIBILITY. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY IS A TARGETED APPROACH
USING EXISTING TECHNOLOGY. THAT
OTHER STATES ARE USING. ADDING
AN ELECTRONIC BALLOT RETURN
OPTION CALIFORNIA FOR VOTERS OF
THE QUALIFYING DISABILITIES. IS
GOOD FOR ACCESSIBILITY. IT'S
TECHNOLOGICALLY POSSIBLE IT'S
SUFFICIENTLY SECURE IMPRACTICAL
TO IMPLEMENT FOR COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS. FOR THESE REASONS THE
R. C. SUPPORTS THIS BILL. AND
THANK YOU AND WE REQUEST YOUR I.
THANK YOU SIR. DO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR SUPPORT. WITH THE HELP AND
ASSISTANCE OF OUR SERGEANT SIR
PLEASE VERIFY YOURSELF. NAME
POSITION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. THERE HAS GOING GUYS
MANY TESTERS AND I AM WITH THE
LINE CCB ORGANIZATION I AM THE
TREASURER RIGHT NOW AND I AM IN
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR. THE SERGEANTS WILL HELP YOU
THE NEXT WITNESS. SIR PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MATTHEW GET
AND I AM PART OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL BLIND STUDENTS AS THE-
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
FEARS WE HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS
HERE IN THE ROOM.
YEAH. WELCOME J. WITH DIFFERENT
. A MY NAME IS OBVIOUS AND FIRST
FACE THAT OF THE GUN FLOODPLAIN
STUDENTS AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE IN THE ROOM TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. WITH OVER THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORT. STRUCTURE
LIKE WE HAVE SOME PARDON WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT
DOG I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME WE I
SKIPPED OVER VERY IMPORTANT
POPULATION. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT STATING NAME AND
POSITION. ON THE BILL. YES IF
YOU ARE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
THE FIFTH THEIR MEMBERS THREE TO
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARK
AND UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. IN THE
PARK. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN Q.
MODERATOR. YES WE DO WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY THREE ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. GO AHEAD TWENTY THREE
. GOOD MORNING JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. M. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT I
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES TO WISHING TO SPEAK IN
Q. IN OPPOSITION. YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TEST RAN OUT WE HAVE SOMEONE
HERE ON THE LINE. TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PROCEED
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
KIM ALEXANDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER FOUNDATION AND
WE OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY AS
EXPRESSED IN THE DRAIN POSITION
LETTER WE CO AUTHORED WITH
VERIFIED VOTING AND ALSO
ENDORSED BY THE BRENNAN CENTER
WE RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THIS
BILL BE AMENDED TO STUDY RATHER
THAN OPEN THE DOOR TO IMPLEMENT
ALTERNATIVE BALLOT RETURN
METHODS FOR VOTERS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES. THE ARGUMENT THAT
OTHER STATES ARE DOING THIS-
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TO WAS MADE
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN PAPERLESS
ELECTRONIC VOTING STARTED TO BE
WIDELY ADOPTED RATHER THAN GOING
ALONG WITH WHAT EVERYONE ELSE
WAS DOINGCALIFORNIA'S LAWMAKERS
TOOK THE LEAD IN PIVOTING OUR
STATE AND NATION TOWARD VOTER
VERIFIED PAPER BALLOTS OTHER
STATES FOLLOW CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
AND BY TWENTY TWENTY PAPERLESS.
VOTING WAS ALMOST ENTIRELY
AROUND A KID WHEN I HERE'S
LOSING PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
REFUSED TO CONCEDE AND INSISTED
AND CONTINUES TO INSIST THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN FROM HIM
THROUGH WIDE SCALE ELECTION
FRAUD IT LED TO VIOLENT
POLITICAL EXTREMIST CONSPIRING
TO HALT THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION RESULTING IN A BLOODY
INSURRECTION IN OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL WITH THREATS TO HANG THE
VICE PRESIDENT LAWMAKERS AND
STAFF CARRYING IN THEIR OFFICES
AND FIVE LIVES LOST. FORTUNATELY
95% OF THE BALLOTS HAD BEEN CAST
ON PAPER ILYIN THOSE BALLOTS
WERE AUDITED COUNTED AND
RECOUNTED GIVING ALEXION
OFFICIALS THE EVIDENCE THEY
NEEDED TO RESPOND THE RATIONS
BIG LIE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ABLE TO ASSURE VOTERS ARE
ELECTIONS ARE SECURE BECAUSE OUR
STATE VOTING SYSTEMS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BE CONNECTED TO THE
AT. PLEASE DO NOT IN THE DOOR
MORE. ELECT VOTING AS OVER THE
INTERNET AND INTRODUCED RISKY
VOTING PRACTICES CALIFORNIA
SHOULD REMAIN A LEADER AND
ELECTION SECURITY. SECURITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY ARE NOT VALUES IN
VOTING SYSTEMS THAT MUST BE
BALANCED WITHOUT SECURITY THERE
IS NO VOTING SYSTEM THERE ARE
MANY WAYS WE CAN IMPROVE THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF OUR VOTING
SYSTEM WITHOUT SUBVERTING IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW DO WE
HAVE DOCTOR JEFFERSON. YES THANK
YOU SENATORS- HI I'M DAVID
JEFFERSON AND I'M A COMPUTER
SCIENTIST WHO'S BEEN STUDYING
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY AND
INTERNET VOTING IN PARTICULAR
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS I HAVE
ALSO SERVED IN ADVISORY CAPACITY
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIVE SECRETARIES OF
STATE AND TODAY I REPRESENT-
FREE SPEECH FOR PEOPLE AND OVER
THIRTY OTHER ELECTION INTEGRITY
ORGANIZATIONS. JOINT OPPOSING
THIS BILL WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
DISABLED VOTERS DO FACE SERIOUS
VOTING OBSTACLES AND WE APPLAUD
THOSE INTENT TO HELP THEM VOTE
PRIVATELY AND INDEPENDENTLY BUT
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
WILL MAKE DISABLED VOTERS
BALLOTS VULNERABLE TO
MANIPULATION BY BY US- CYBER
ATTACKS. INTERACTION THE-
INTEGRITY OF ALL CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS THE DANGER THAT WE
BELIEVE OVERRIDES THE
ACCESSIBILITY ADVANTAGE MIGHT
OTHERWISE PROVIDE ELECTRONIC R.
A. B. B. M. AS CONTEMPLATED IN
THIS BILL IS JUST A FORM OF
INTERNET VOTING AND AS SUCH IT
IS SUBJECT TO A WHOLE SUITE OF
PROFOUNDLY DANGEROUS SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES INHERITED BY ALL
SUCH SYSTEMS THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCES THE
TRIPOLI S. SISTER MISSED THE EAC
THE F. B. I. AND NUMEROUS
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS AND STUDIES
HAVE ALL WARNED OF THE DANGERS
AND IT CONCLUDES. THAT NO FEE OF
INR COULD BE IMPLEMENTED ANYTIME
SOON AND NOT IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE THESE PROBLEMS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE OVERCOME ANY TIME
AND SHE ABLE FUTURE MAYBE
SOMEDAY. BUT NOT NOW. THERE'S NO
WAY TO TRANSMIT SECRET BALLOT
SECURELY OVER THE INTERNET. SUCH
BALLOTS IN ANY CASE WOULD NOT BE
EITHER MEANINGFULLY VOTER
VERIFIABLE NOR AUDITABLE. WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT ANOTHER
PROVISION OF THE BILL WHICH
WOULD ALLOW DISABLED VOTERS TO
VOTE BY FAX UNTIL AND UNLESS AN
ELECTRONIC BALLOT RETURN SYSTEM
IS CERTIFIED. FAXES ARE NOT WHAT
THEY USED TO BE ESSENTIALLY ALL
FAXES TODAY ARE TRANSMITTED OVER
THE INTERNET SO FACT VOTING IS
JUST ANOTHER FORM OF INTERNET
VOTING. IN ADDITION FAX ITSELF
AS A TECHNOLOGY IS OF SECURITY
DISASTER DOWN THERE AT THE
BOTTOM WITH EMAIL I'M AFRAID-
FAXES ARE NOT END TO END
ENCRYPTED CALLER ID AND PHONE
NUMBERS. ARE EASILY AFFORDABLE-
THE PROVISION IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR IMAGES OF VOTER
SIGNATURES INSTEAD OF WET INK
SIGNATURES. ALLOWS THEM TO BE
FORGED SO IN SUMMARY. WE
STRONGLY URGE THE CALIFORNIA NOT
AUTHORIZED THE CERTIFICATION OF
ANY FORM OF OUR IBM OR EXTEND
FAX VOTING TO ANYONE. IN FACT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU YOU
CONSIDER REMOVING ALL USE
AFFECTS VOTING FROM CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS CODE. ADJOURNMENTS
THANK YOU SIR. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN ONE TWELVE
HERE WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND THE OTHER WITNESSES HERE.
MODERATOR COULD YOU TAKE A POLL
OF THE IN QUEUE FOR. CITIZENS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT. I WE ARE SUPPORT FOR-
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY MISTER CHAIR. YES WE DID NOT IF THE
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM I. DO
HAVE ANY. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE AND ONE TWELVE.
MODERATOR DO ANY OPPOSITION.
THAT HAVE FIGURES BUT LET'S
LET'S GO UNDER THE ANYBODY THAT
THERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET
SOME SUPPORT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
OKAY. WOLDERS OPERAS FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW- FOR
THE- SB FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY EUROPE YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH LIKE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YES MY NAME IS
PATRICIA GRATION- I AM BELONG TO
ELECTION INTEGRITY GROUPS FOR
DECADES AND I KNOW THAT ANYTHING
ELECTRONIC- OF COMING INTO OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM IS REALLY
ANATHEMA TO A PRE ELECTION EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT TRANSPARENT
ELECTIONS WHERE PEOPLE CAN KNOW
FOR SURE THAT THEIR VOTES WERE
NOT TAMPERED WITH- TRYING I AM
VERY- VERY ANXIOUS. THAT WE NOT
ALLOW THAT KIND OF- ENTRYWAY
INTO OUR VOTING SYSTEM IT IT IT
OPENS THE DOOR TO ANSWERING LOTS
OF PRIVACY. THANK OF THE
INTEGRITY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MODERATOR ANY OTHER I WILL. YES
WE HAVE A NUMBER CUTE OUT MISTER
CHAIR I WILL GO TO ONE THIRTEEN
YOU'RE OPEN. NINE THIRTEEN WELL
MY NAME IS SUSAN. HI MY NAME IS
SUSAN GREEN ON IN YOUR VISOR-
ELECTION SECURITY AT FREE SPEECH
FOR PEOPLE AND REMAIN STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY.
THANK YOU. FIND EIGHTEEN YOUR
GROWTH EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN AND HIDE THEIR ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEFENDING THE
LIBERTIES IN THE DIGITAL WORLD
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MY NAME'S CHRISTOPHER DARK
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU YOU
. BOOK YOUR OPEN SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTEEN ARE
YOU MUTED. IS HIS NAME. CORRECT. MY NAME IS JIM SO CULTURE THE
NATIONAL VOTING RIGHTS THAT
FLOWS STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS NOT TRIED NOT READY
. THANK YOU SIR. OVERALL I
TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. I AM
THINKING FREE CHILDHOOD CAMPING
CORRECTOR OF DEMOCRACY CAMPAIGNS
AT PUBLIC CITIZEN RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AT THIS TIME. MY TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER
HANNER ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM AND THEY
HAVE A LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
ACTION COALITION AND VALIDATE
THE VOTE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY
INTERNET VOTING TWO RISKY FOR
SECURE ELECTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND THE STRUCTURE WILL
OPEN LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS FUTURE CALLS REPRESENTING
VERIFIED VOTING AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS TELEMEDICINE
MENDEZ AS EXPLAINED BY ACTING
OUT THEN- FROM CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AMATEUR WE HAVE ONE THAT YOU END
UP WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE SHOULD BE RIGHT WITH US.
HELLO LINE THIRTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS MANY
KENNEDY AND I'M WITH THE-
ALEXION ISSUES HALF OF
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS OF AMERICA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
. THANK YOU THIS YEAR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. OKAY THAT
WILL BE IT ANY OTHER IN Q.
MODERATOR DAHLE. THAT AT THIS
TIME MR PRAYER WILL RETURN TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND WE THANK YOU
WITNESSES FOR AND OPPOSED TO
HAVE TESTIFIED. MR UNDER HARPER
THANK YOU ONE. YEAH I JUST HEARD
MANY KENNEDY MY NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBOR OPPOSE YOUR BILL SO I
WILL MOVE IT AT THE END THAT
WITH THE RIGHT TO TALK TO HER
BECAUSE I WANT TO LISTEN TO WHAT
SHE HAS TO SAY AS I GO FORWARD
TO THEY GIVE YOU A CHANCE BUT-
I'LL VOTE FOR IT MOVE IT TODAY
BUT I'M- I'M GONNA TALK TO ME BC
WHICH IS TO SAY. I ALWAYS GOOD
TO GO BACK TO THE HOME QUOTE
FOLKS YOU KNOW. CARE UNDER YEAH
I WANT TO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
TALK TO CENTERS FOR ITS NEXT OR
NEIGHBORS WELL- CHAU ISSUE
SENATOR GLAZERS AYE AYE I KNOW
YOU TO BE A- VERY DETAIL
ORIENTED PERSON SO I. YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD A BUNCH OF TESTIMONY
AS TO THE- SECURITY OR LACK OF
SECURITY AROUND. R. A. V. B. M.
VOTING TO WITH THEM MISTER
JEFFERSON OTHERS. SO YOU KNOW
HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT THAT
AND JUST IMPORTANT TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE DO SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR FOR. THE OVERSEAS
MILITARY. WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
IF ANY. ALL SIDES OF COMMON
TESTIFIED BEFORE US TODAY LOOK
WE- WE ALL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
SECURITY IT'S A HEART AND SOUL
OF- OF OUR SECRET BALLOT A
PROCESS- THAT SECRETARY STATES
CHARGE WITH THE INSURANCE AT
THAT PROCESS TAKES PLACE
APPROPRIATELY YOU KNOW THEY
CERTIFY ALL THE VOTING MACHINES
EVERY COUNTY- SO THERE IS THERE
IS. IT RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROCESS IS
DONE- THOUGHTFULLY AND WILL-
AND- AT THIS BILL ONLY PERMITS
THE SECRETARY STATE TO IF IN THE
END IN THIS CASE IN HER-
EXPERIENCE. AND WISDOM AND
ADVICE THAT THERE IS SUCH A
SYSTEM THAT CAN BE PUT INTO
PLACE THAT. THAT THAT SHE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
DO THAT PROVIDE BETTER ACCESS SO
THAT'S ALL THE BILL DOES. IS
GIVES US HER THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE WHETHER THEY'RE IF THERE
EVER IS IN A- SITUATION WHERE.
YOU HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS SECURE
THAT SHE COULD ADVANCE THAT AND
HELP. THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITY HAVE
ACCESS THE BALLOT WHICH IS A
PART. OF OUR- HALLMARK OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IS HAVING ACCESS TO
FIVE. SHOWS YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE
YOU'VE ALLOWED FOR THAT PURPOSE
OF THE SECTOR STATE WOULD. WOULD
VALIDATE THE SECURITY I CAN'T GO
INTO EFFECT AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE PLUS IS IT JUST LIKE ANY
VOTING SYSTEM AND STATE TODAY.
IN AND OUT OF CURIOSITY MAY I
YOU KNOW THAT I THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO INFER TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE LEVERAGE OUR DOOR
SORRY BUT OVERSEAS MILITARY
VOTE- THE VIEWER SHOWING THAT
THAT'S NOT GONNA BE DISPOSITIVE
RIGHT THERE. IN IN THE RESULT
FROM ELECTION RIGHT BECAUSE WE
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN IT'S
ENTIRELY SECURE IN THE SAME WAY.
SO HOW BIG IS THIS COHORT BUT
PROSPECTIVELY DISABLED VOTERS
15% OF VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
A DISABILITY. SO IT'S QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL SO CLEARLY
SUBSTANTIAL ENOUGH TO INFLUENCE
THE OUTCOME. OF A RELATIVE OF A
CLOSE ELECTION INDEED BUT YET
AGAIN WITH A IT TO I DON'T WANT
TO JUMP AHEAD TO WHAT THAT
SYSTEM WOULD BE. BECAUSE I YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE TECHNOLOGY
QUESTION. THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE
GOOD WILL AND- HAVE THOUGHTS ON
. THE LOOKED AT IT BE A SO THAT
PRINTS ABOUT. OUT THE
SECRETARY'S OFFICE. IT COULD BE
A SYSTEM THAT WHERE YOU HAVE A
PAPER TRAIL AND MADE BY TERRY
WILL BE PART OF WHAT. THAT
TECHNOLOGY MIGHT PROVIDE IN THE
YEARS AHEAD- TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S A VERIFIABLE THAT. TRAIL
OF ONE'S VOTE- AT EDINA SECURE
WAY BUT I'M NOT GONNA JUMP AHEAD
AND SAY THIS IS THE SYSTEM. I
THINK THAT WE WANT TO GIVE THE
SECRETARY STATE THE ABILITY TO.
EXAMINE ALL THESE OPTIONS
THOUGHTFULLY AS I KNOW THAT. SHE
WILL AND FUTURE SECRETARY STATES
WOULD AS WELL. JOINT AGED
SEVENTY FAIR TO INFER FROM YOUR
ANSWER THE YOU'RE YOU'RE MORE
THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH.
ANYBODY WITH AN INTEREST IN. YOU
KNOW AUDITABILITY SECURITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IN FACT IS
PRESENT CORRECT. IN ADDITION
INDICATE INDEED THAT WE SHARE
THE SAME. GOALS OF HAVING SECURE
ELECTIONS. AND I THINK THAT
WILL. TO WITH THEM ON. ANY KIND
OF CHECKS OR BALANCES THAT THEY
THINK SHOULD BE PUT IN THE BILL
TO PROTECT- THE SECURITY OF THE
BALLOT A VERY OPEN TO A TO
WORKING WITH THEM ON. BUT I DO
WANT TO GIVE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THE ABILITY TO DO THE
THOUGHTFUL REVIEW. OF ANY SYSTEM
THAT COMES FOR ANY TECHNOLOGY TO
SEE WHETHER IT MEETS THAT TEST.
THANK YOU READY GLAD WITH THE
BILL OF THE PROJECT. THEY GIVE
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HELLO
LET ME HAZARD A- CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN WATCHED THESE ELECTION
BILLS FOR DECADES. THEY ALWAYS
HAVE INTENDED OR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THERE WAS RECENTLY
SOME LEGISLATION TO ALLOW
ASSISTANCE TO DISABLED CITIZEN.
TO HELP THEM BE ABLE TO VOTE IT
WAS LATER EXPANDED AND THEN.
MADE OF ALMOST PERMANENT WITH
COVERED NINETEEN. THAT NOTION
THAT WASN'T NECESSARILY INTENDED
AND IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
RESULT IN GREATER ELECTION
INTEGRITY OR PARTICIPATION.
FRANKLY OVER THE DECADES IF YOU
REVIEW THE VOTER PARTICIPATION
WITH ALL OF THE MEASURES THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED IN
THE PEOPLE AS WELL. TO ENHANCE
VOTER PARTICIPATION HASN'T DONE
MUCH BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONTINUING PROBLEM. MAYBE THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE INVENTED MAYBE
THEY'RE REAL BUT THAT'S THE
CONSEQUENCE THAT CAN ENSUE. AND
THAT IS MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. ALL THAT WOULD
GIVE A CLOSE SENATORS BETTER
DEALS THAT I WOULD JUST SAY THIS
THAT- WE ALL WON A SECRET BALLOT
TO BE A PLACE AND- ACCOUNTABLE
AND SAVE- IT'S THE HALLMARK OF
OUR DEMOCRACY WE HAVE WORKED
VERY HARD AS A LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE A VOTE BY MAIL. AND
WE'VE ADVANCE THAT IN THERE'S
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME INTO PLAY
IN THAT SPACE THE SECRETARY
STATUS PROVIDE STANDARDS WE ALSO
WEIGH IN WITH STANDARDS I THINK
THAT WILL HAPPEN IF- THEY WANT.
TO GO FORWARD WITH THE POWERS
THAT BE PROVIDE THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED IN THIS BILL OVER THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. WHAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PART SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BOOK FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER. GLAZER HI
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG
HI HERTZBERG HI LEYVA AYE LEYVA
HI NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN HI. BORDER
ONE THAT CHAIRED A NIELSEN THAT
BILLS OUT OF RIBBONS HERE WE'RE
GONNA GO DOWN AND CALL THE ROLL
IN ON FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON
PREVIOUS BILLS WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TEN
SIXTY I LAYERED OF THE CONSOLE
WOULD CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
ONE SB TEN SIXTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR VOTING
I AM THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
WITH A CURRENT FOCUS TWO TO ONE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI. ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS
OUT FOUR ONE IS THAT CORRECT
CONSULTANT WILL MOVE NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO
BY CENTER ALLEN SOLD CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM TWO SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THE LEAD TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HIGH
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI. RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT FOR TWO ONE IS THAT
CORRECT CONSULTANT OKAY THAT
COMPLETES OUR AGENDA TODAY. WANT
TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO- JOINED
AND PARTICIPATED IN OUR
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSIONS. AT
THE RATE I'M NOT ABLE TESTIFIED
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. COMMENT GESTIONES ARE
POURED INTO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- AND WITH THAT
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE. ON
ELECTIONS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE HERE. GOOD
JOB OF THE JOB THANKS GUYS THE.